hi everyone
thanks for joining we're excited to talk
to you today about the desk list
workforce
and how you can digitize and streamline
their work without writing a line of
code
we'll talk about who the desk-less
workforce is what are the challenges
they're facing
and how organizations can use app sheet
apps to solve those challenges and boost
productivity we'll walk through several
great examples of what these apps look
like
and how they are actually being used in
the field
now before we jump in we'd like to give
a quick introduction to who we are
my name is chris bailey i'm a product
marketing manager on the google app
sheet team
and was actually with aptc before it was
acquired by google in january this year
and i'm very excited to be joined by
johnny hacking who is the director of it
at bhi
johnny would you like to introduce
yourself and maybe give
a little background about bhi as well
awesome thanks chris hi i'm johnny
hacking and i'm the i.t director here at
bhi
and have been for the past three years
and i've been in the i.t
field for over 15 years now bhi is a
turnkey
general contractor that began as an
electrical contractor
and has grown into a company that serves
the civil pipeline
communication electrical and renewable
energy
industries across the united states now
we've already mentioned appsheet a
couple times and i realized that many
people are just learning about it
so i wanted to start off by giving a
quick intro introduction and overview to
what app sheet is
appshi is a no code application
development platform that enables anyone
to create apps
fast at a high level it's a simple
process
first you connect your data app sheet
can connect to a wide variety of data
sources
including excel files google sheets
cloud sql and on-premise databases
then you can customize your app within
the app sheet editor and create and
adjust
views workflows notifications and more
finally you can deploy your applications
out to both mobile and desktop devices
and apps she does an excellent job of
being responsive and working on all of
these devices
so while app she integrates with a wide
variety of software
we found that it is particularly
powerful when combined with g suite
the two products work together in many
ways you can store app data and content
on drive
you can build an app directly on top of
sheets and create
read update and delete sheets data from
the app
you can open up google meet use docs as
templates
create and update calendar invites and
extend your forms functionality
there's a lot of goodness that comes
from using the two platforms together
and i definitely recommend exploring how
you can use them to solve your business
challenges
so that's a high level overview of what
app sheet is now we want to shift the
topic
and focus more on the desktopless
workforce and the ways we can utilize
app sheet to enable those teams
eighty percent of the global workforce
is deskless
these are people working in the field
and on the floor who have to get up
and move around and don't spend the
majority of their time next to a
computer
think of field technicians construction
workers
sales representatives doctors nurses
event managers
manufacturing specialists just to name a
few
more and more we're seeing desk less
workers looking to technology to find
ways to improve productivity and
efficiency
and these challenges they are facing are
different from those faced by desk
workers
for example while it may be very easy
for someone sitting at a desk to open up
a new sheet
write up an invoice you know adjust
margins and formatting
that can be a lot more that can be much
more difficult for someone who's in the
field
as they may not have a computer and
they may be on their mobile phone or
tablet where it's just trickier to
format a document and perform actions
like that
now bhi's deskless workers have been
using app sheet in some really
interesting ways
so i actually want to pass it over to
johnny to talk about those challenges
they were facing
and how they use app sheet to solve them
awesome thanks so the challenge we faced
was we were required to submit multiple
inspection forms
on a daily basis for one of our projects
and current processes just didn't work
it was to fill out paper forms in the
field and then later inputting that data
to send off from a computer either at a
hotel
job trailer or other location this
needed to be done
for all inspections that day which were
multiple
sometimes 30 plus and we didn't have the
manpower to meet these requirements
for this project management looked to
i.t
for a solution because hiring more
people would put the project's success
in jeopardy
the current process was not working
forms and spreadsheets brought
challenges of managing data
and workflows across multiple jobs
developers can be costly
and external solutions are inflexible
because it's never just one external
solution
you know we have multiple divisions here
at bhi
and they all have different needs now
bhi had just migrated to g
suite and was having great success with
the collaboration it brought
and that's when we found the app sheet
on top of g suite
gave us the ability to take full
advantage of these digital platforms
it gave us the offline capability in an
actual app and was easy for our users in
the field
that are in very different working
conditions
aptchy works seamless with google sheets
and docs making it easy to push out
applications fast and simple
actually one of the apps in the demo you
will see later we made in a matter of
hours on a job site in a job trailer
customization of app sheet has helped
save money because we are custom making
apps for specific
jobs that sometimes only get used once
for a project
one thing to know is that it isn't just
it that is developing these apps but
people from multiple teams
to help make them better because a lot
of the times they understand the needs
of their project better than we do
i t is just brought in as a final step
to review the app before it goes live
since using app sheet i've been told
multiple times on job sites
how much they love the apps and to keep
them coming because they're making their
job a lot easier
now aptchy has solved a lot of our
problems and transformed the way we work
as a company it's ease of use allows for
my small team to deploy apps
that meet the requirements of multiple
disciplines rapidly
forms that are required on every job are
now digital
and filled out on the fly with all the
data being stored in google drive
apps aren't just forms though but
something that is tailored for each job
we have ones that are used across the
entire company and others specific to
projects because of the information
gathered and reported in real time
this has cut costs by reducing our
overall i.t budget by 10
when we normally paid that to other
third-party softwares
and an example is some quality
inspections on electrical work
was taking up to two hours to do one
inspection
by the time everything was filled out
and inputted into a pdf
combined with pictures taken on site and
emailed
to the client on a daily basis from a
computer back in the office
not only did our apps allow this to
happen in the field
but they also cut down these inspection
forms from two hours to six
minutes this was the solution to our
challenge in the previous slide
the result was money saved and we're
able to meet the job requirements
appsheet has also given us more time
with two of our app sheet apps
for one department completely freed up
20 to 30 hours a week
this time was generally spent on
printing and scanning forms to manually
inputting data
into a spreadsheet so that it could be
analyzed
now our workflows do this in a matter of
minutes
we are now making decisions on data
that's happening now versus what
happened two weeks ago
the best part about this is our
employees are coming up with new
innovative
ways we can use app sheet which isn't
happening in conference rooms but across
construction sites all over the country
awesome now johnny if it's okay let's
actually walk through
some of the apps you've created with
your team and talk about how they've
been beneficial for the mobile workers
so this is our company dashboard app
it's a basically we call it bhi relay
and it's a a bunch of apps you can see
that we've created
for a lot of use cases such as equipment
rentals time tracking pto
and hr forms with the company being as
diverse as it is it's an easy
one-stop shop for people to find what
they need regardless of their department
great now let's open up a couple of
these apps and walk through how they're
actually being used
so let's click on safety apps demo which
will open up another menu of safety
specific apps
and let's look at the near miss report
awesome so yeah this is filled out
whenever there's an incident that almost
occurs on a
on a job site or in an office building
anything like that
so if it were to happen and i was an
employee i could either
notify my foreman or myself um if i was
in that position i could
come to here and first off the view
you're going to see
is all the near miss forms that i've
filled out in the past or if i was a
foreman i would
be able to see ones that i have filled
out or
ones that have been filled out for the
employees that i'm over
and if once i open this up i'm right
here in the bottom right there's a plus
and let's say
i need to fill out a near miss i'm going
to hit that plus
which is going to bring us to the form
and start walking us through here
fill out our incident location where
this happened out in the building
jander closet parking lot whatever
and then right here in the near miss you
get to section
um we've had times like this as a
construction company we do work for
other people and sometimes
the companies we do work for they
require us to use their forms
well we want people our employees to use
the app because
it's very important for what we do but
at the same time we don't want to be
requiring our employees to fill out
three or four
different type of forms and wasting
all that time when they can be doing
other things and so we made it easy for
them
to select the picture item and then they
could click on the picture icon
and actually take a picture of the near
miss they filled out
and i'll interject here and just say
that when you select picture
and are on a mobile device it'll just
open up the camera right there
so that you can actually take a picture
of the form and save it down to your app
we also created that for a file because
on some jobs
people someone else has filled out the
near miss
for that other company and then emailed
us a pdf copy will give us a way that
it's given us a way there that we can
click on file click on that icon
and browse to a pdf or some other
document on the computer and upload it
as well
but let's say for this instance
sometimes we don't have those we can
click
n a and then that is going to present us
with the rest
of the information that we need to fill
out in order to complete the near-miss
form
and so as uh we're just going to kind of
go down and fill out some of the data
answer the questions
and one thing i really like here and
which is huge with all our safety apps
is sometimes uh it's nice to be able to
require the information that needs to be
filled out
yeah so essentially everything with a
star is required
and if you try to move on to the next
step without filling those out you'll
get an error
and you can also set additional
parameters on those requirements like
specifying that it has to be an email or
a number or something like that
and then we're going to get down here
with the employee signature
just so you know that if you are on a
tablet or a smart device
and you click on that you'll be able to
just draw with your finger
or a stylus or whatever and actually
capture people's realized signatures
and then at the very bottom you can fill
in an email address if for some reason
you needed to email a copy of this near
miss
to that person for reporting purposes
you fill that in once it saves app sheet
has a workflow that combines this
information puts it into a pdf
and emails it off to that person
now that we've hit save you can see all
that it's been added with the other
in your misses that have been filled out
and it's right here
and we have done our job now
there's one more app that i think is
really clever that we want to show you
the time entry app so yeah this app is
really interesting because uh coveted
just happened
and we needed to create something that
would meet all the requirements
of social distancing um and not to touch
as many surfaces as possible
as we could for this job site and to
keep track of time
people would just click on a tablet and
punch it in well not with this case we
created a solution so we didn't have to
on setup here each employee will be in
the list
and we'd add employees and we'd give
everyone a barcode
that was a sticker and we'd put that
underneath their hard hat
from there every day the person in
charge of time would click on check in
and what that would do is it would open
up this scanned
section and if you were on a tablet it
would open up the camera itself and it
would just stay open all the time
what would happen is when a barcode is
filled in or
you hold the bar their hard hat with the
barcode sticker
the camera will recognize that fill in
the barcode
it will save it and automatically go to
the next one
and it will just keep doing this all day
until that person would come back and
get the tablet
at which everyone has been clocked in
for the day not happen to touch the ipad
or the tablet or anything
at this point you're likely curious to
see what these applications look like on
the back end
so i'm going to open up the app sheet
editor and show you what it looks like
so let's look at the time entry app that
johnny just showed us and see what it
looks like behind the scenes
now all of that apps data is hosted in
this google sheet
it has two tabs the first with a simple
table that will update as people clock
in and out
and the second with the employees emails
and associated barcodes
to create an app all you'd have to do to
get started is to pull up app sheet and
connect it to a spreadsheet like this
so let's see what it looks like in the
app editor
this is the app sheet editor over here
on the right you can see a live preview
of the app
and you can switch to different views
whether you want to see phone tablet or
desktop views
on the far left we have the main menu of
edit options
the key ones you need to know when
you're getting started are info
which gives high level information about
your app data
which lets you build and update your
tables columns and slices
ux where you can adjust the look and
feel of the app and behavior
where you can set up actions workflows
and reports
let me highlight a few key features of
this app
so when we go to data tables in this
time tracker app
we can see that the same tables in the
spreadsheet are also listed out here
timesheet and setup when we select
view columns we see that all the columns
were added as well
there's also some additional columns
that have been created to add
functionality to the app
and several of them if we look here
include formulas that we've added to
help
run the logic of the app
next if you wanted to adjust the look
and feel of the app
you can go to ux brand and easily change
your app
to light mode or dark mode and adjust
your colors
which you can see being updated in the
live preview here
now let's say you wanted to have an
automated report sent to the payroll
manager
that showed how long each employee
worked that day
that report is simple to set up you can
go to behavior
reports and select new report
here we've already created one so let's
just open that up to give you an idea of
what that report can look like
so daily at 8 pm mountain time
use the today's timetable
which just so you know is a virtual
table or slice that we created within
this app
we don't have to set additional
conditions so let's leave that section
blank
and do this let's send an email to these
two addresses
with this information
and and note here that you can have
piped text too
and let's also send a text message so
that they know the report is in their
inbox
so you update all this and after that
you can click save
test the report out once or twice and
start using it
now i'm going to stop the demo here
because unfortunately we don't have time
to go through every piece of this app
but we have extensive documentation
online
as well as a very active app sheet
community
that can help you get started and answer
any questions you have
now before we end we wanted to just give
you a few more ideas
of other common apps we see customers
building for their desk-less workers
we've talked a lot about field service
and inspections and audits
but we also see people using app sheet
for inventory management
project management such as on-site
budget tracking and worker management
human resources such as onboarding
training and time sheets
and sales and marketing which is
especially useful when you have a mobile
workforce that spends a lot of time out
in the field
talking to prospects and customers
hopefully this presentation has given
you some valuable information
on how you can better enable your mobile
workforce if you'd like to learn more
about app sheet or start creating apps
you can get started at appsheet.com so
thank you for watching this presentation
and happy app building